there's been a lot of pain in this city
over the last five years and there's
been a lot of fear the pain was because
we watched an innocent man die and the
fear was because people worried that
there would be no justice that the
inequities that have plagued us for
generations would simply continue
unchecked but today for the first time
in these long five years the system of
justice is working for the garner family
and I've spent time with them I've heard
the pain that they have felt there's
been a very long five years with no
sense of closure no sense of justice
until today the garner family has been
failed by this entire process and think
about what they have gone through they
watched him die just as we all did they
felt that pain and then they were told
over and over again by the district
attorney by the Department of Justice
that the government would do its job and
they waited and they waited and they
waited and nothing happened and as all
this stretched on it reinforced the
suspicion as one felt by millions that
justice doesn't exist for people who
look like Eric garner today we finally
saw a step towards justice and
accountability we saw a process that was
actually fair and impartial and I hope
that this will now bring the garner
family a sense of closure and the
beginning of some peace but full justice
means that they can never be another
tragedy like the one that befell Eric
garner full justice is when we never
have another death that is all of our
responsibility and it requires us to
change everything for the last five
years our mission has been to
fundamentally change the nature of
policing in New York City after the
death of Eric garner everything was
really a 'td the entire police force was
retrained 36,000 officers retrained to
de-escalate conflict to understand the
implicit bias that we all carry with us
to ensure it would not interfere with
their duty the approach to the community
is entirely different today and we had
to weed out the distance and the
separation that was the norm of the past
and through neighborhood policing
actually created dynamic for our
officers and community members got to
know each other as human beings where
people felt they were on the same side
working toward a common goal and we had
to change the approach on the ground
last year there were a hundred fifty
thousand fewer arrests than five years
earlier because there were too many
times when people were being arrested
unnecessarily and too many conflicts
that came from it and this NYPD proved
that fewer and fewer people could be
arrested and the city could become safer
safety and fairness must walk hand in
hand and I hoped
today begins the process of restoring
some faith and helping people believe
that there actually is accountability
and fairness we have a lot more work to
do
we'll be at this a long time but we all
have a sense of common mission there can
never be another tragedy like this this
city this nation should never be put
through this agony we should never lose
another innocent man or woman we should
never have people's faith undermined
it's in our power to do something better
and to do something different that is
the course we set five years ago and
that's the course we will stay on few
words in Spanish boy
finalmente BMO's un paso hacia la
aplicación de justicia espero que esta
decisión ley dare a la familia gone una
sensación de cierra trabajar amos para
asegurar knows que algo como esto nunca
well bah I said I'm going to take a few
questions now but I want to say up front
and I want to remind everyone this is an
ongoing legal matter so there's very
little I can add to my statement but I
do want to take a few questions yes
we'll get you the history multiple
conversations again what I'm talking
about today is a fair and impartial
process has occurred that's all I had to
say no I have not look I haven't heard
what he said today I know members of
Congress want to look at this issue I
certainly think it's fair to say here
was a tragedy it cannot happen again and
what I would ask the members of Congress
to look at is the role of Justice
Department going forward remember and I
said it earlier on the radio we had
three horrifying cases that we all
remember too well Louima case the bail
case and the Diala case in every one of
them there was prosecution either by the
Justice Department or the District
Attorney what's happening his last five
years is unfathomable there was no
decision even from the Justice
Department that's a central question to
me Marcia that can't happen again the
future there has to be a decision on a
meaningful timeline
they have to I think they have to beg
this very important question Justice
Department has to ensure speedy justice
it's right there in the Constitution
that can't be a process that goes on
five years ever again I'm not gonna go
into private conversations today as I
said it's a legal matter yeah I believe
the process was fair and impartial and
it's the first time we've seen a
decision I want to remind everyone over
five years
District Attorney did not bring an
indictment therefore there was no trial
Justice Department did not bring an
indictment therefore there was no trial
for the first time there was a trial a
fair and impartial trial and a result
remember that point about justice
delayed is justice denied that least
there was a trial and a result and I
have faith it was a fair and impartial
process
Oh put a place we never wait on the
Justice Department again do you regret
waiting on the Justice Department and
not going ahead with a profile 2015
absolutely I cannot understand how this
happened everything I had seen my entire
life suggested the Justice Department
believed it was its responsibility to
act when other levels of government had
not or at least to make a decision
quickly for the benefit of justice it's
literally beyond any compare I cannot
find any parallel to what happened here
and it's an unacceptable reality I did
not think it possible honestly I didn't
think it was possible under either
administration federally but now that
we've experienced it we will never allow
that to happen again
Gloria
and why don't you say when you first
with your personal opinion
is now that we have this recreation from
the job like you
if you believe that there's a fair and
impartial process and I do then letting
it reach its conclusion beyond reproach
beyond question is necessary and I am
talking as the steward of this city
we need closure in the city the garner
family deserves at first and foremost
but we as a city need to end this
chapter and move forward
I believe my role is to respect this
process and respect the state law and
that's the best way to get to that
closure Jeff and the state law is
abundantly clear there has to be due
process and I emphasize to everyone that
is an American value everyone in this
room should value due process the
problem here is that we listen to the
United States Justice Department under
two different administrations and we
respected their demand that we hold back
but once it was clear they were not
acting and we move forward we are
governed by state law and that's what
the process has been due process a trial
a decision by a judge a final decision
by the police commissioner yes
some people accept that died it's very
painful that this family's been put
through hell and part of why I'm
reminding all New Yorkers of these
previous horrible situations is to make
clear how wrong this was it's bad enough
that an innocent man died we all saw it
we all felt it but when we think about
the other instances that this whole city
felt we all remember the Diallo case we
all remember the louima case the Bell
case justice proceeded you could agree
or disagree with any element of what
happened but there was a trial the
notion of five years passed without a
trial and that the the place that had
been the ultimate dispenser of justice
failed to act in any way shape or form
is unfathomable and to your point that
family members died in the meantime and
never got to see any closure is
extremely painful and we cannot let that
happen again
to another family
[Music]
I respect everyone who has spoken out in
their pain in their outrage and that's
what I was saying in the beginning I
think so many people feared that we had
not moved forward as a city or as a
society that injustice was simply going
to happen with no result and I
appreciate why people felt that and it
cannot be we can't move forward as a
city we can't move forward as a nation
if people wonder if there's going to be
any justice at all so what was
abundantly clear to me was once a fair
and impartial process occurred it would
change everything that people were
feeling to see an actual process and
that that changes the entire discussion
but there's finally been a trial that
has actually been a decision and it is a
fair and impartial process again this is
only a beginning of restoring people's
faith but this is the kind of thing that
need to happen a long time ago an actual
justice process and now it has happened
thank you everyone